my son just watched a clip of last time
I was on the show and he goes good you
have aged like a president and my
daughter goes I was thinking guacamole
so that's what's going on at my place my
daughter is 14 I didn't realize that
girl's voice has changed when they went
through puberty one time my daughter
goes duh hey if we're gonna make
strawberry and rhubarb pie then why are
you looking at me like that cool I gave
her a chore list with three words on it
she goes where's your chore list I said
what'd you say she goes where's your
just she slowed it down like I didn't
hear her I said you know everything in
this house that happens to make it work
subtract the three things I asked you to
do and that is my chore list remember
when you woke up in a built by a bed
warm and not hungry I mean check check
check I did all of that my chore list
also has three words on it says keep her
alive
and it expires in four years to get your
[ __ ] together she's 14 now and she was
12 I started listening to podcasts about
periods
I'm sure I'm on a list somewhere but
I just didn't want to send her to her
mom's house with all those questions you
know that's a question for your mother
you know where to find me if you want to
play catch one of the podcast said when
you're showing your daughter how to use
the applicator on the tampon you push
the tampon into your hand all right my
hands been a vagina that makes sense
look at their clapping they know just
kept me from running a van into a group
of people great you know I never did
push the tampon into my hand cuz when I
thought about it that just looks like a
magic trick where's the tampon you
better find it cuz toxic shock is real
my daughter had her first period at my
house and she goes dad a couple things
number one got my period number two
don't want to talk about it I said
number one great number two greater she
said we have to go to Mom's house cuz
she bought me some stuff and I said no
dads can buy things so I brought her
upstairs and I opened the closet next to
the laundry room and inside was one box
of all of the each of them
every single kind that they make I did
that walk down the aisle and I go that's
different that's different I mean I'm
not some dumb dad that thought it was
gonna go there and there was gonna be a
box that said daughter's first period
with a donkey and a cowboy hat winking
at you like you got it you can get it
so I told my daughter I go that's all
the ones they make right there that
costs two hundred and seventeen dollars
where I live and if you can't find what
you need in there I'm sorry about your
square vagina
if that's real I'm gonna have to take
her to her mom's house because that was
not on the podcast so she grabbed it and
she goes it's right here I know what I
need guy and she walked away and then I
brought back two hundred and eleven
dollars worth of tampons and that's an
awkward exchange right I did go in get
an empty cart bring it out fill the cart
up and bring it back in and I get to the
return counter and the guy isn't looking
so I go me and he goes all right
checking out and I go mmm
checking him and his face just melted he
goes oh my god what happened that's a
very valid question but I panicked and I
went ah she said pancake mix thank you
guys very much
you